this is the thing is mr. danger
bismillah alhamdulillah Salam alaikum
peace be unto you welcome to another
episode of the Deen show and we're here
in Buffalo New York my hometown and
hamdulillah where I was born and I'm
here with our next guest who's coming up
on the show we interview people from all
over the globe who have accepted the
fastest growing way of life in the world
submission to the will of God that
complete system way of life that
connects you to the crater that heavens
and earth and our next guest went from
now I'm telling you look when we know
what worship is you understand what he
was doing okay so the man grew his hair
out wide because he was following Bob
Marley most of you know the legend
singer Bob Marley so he went from almost
worshipping this man to Islam we want to
hear his story so we're gonna come back
don't go anywhere here with our brother
David on the Dean show we'll be right
back
peace be with us Salam alaikum alaikum
Salam how are you doing brother
humbly well I'm happy to be here as the
pleasure to honor masha'Allah
Bob Marley for the people that don't
know who Bob Marley is tell us he's a
legendary singer you know I mean um he
was from Jamaica Kingston Jamaica he
came with the Rastafari and me growing
up when I was about 17 years old I
really caught on to this startling to
allow the reggae music and end up
growing some a twisted dress then I cut
that and then I went to go to true
Rastafari start growing my natural hair
and just like all wild like it was it
was a mess almost but um I was just a
truth seeker and I'm a soul searcher so
um when I seen that it wasn't something
right about it I had to go look more and
more and find out okay what's the truth
so then I've been throwing up in the
Christianity and then from there that's
what I lit went to Rastafari
and then after Rastafari I went to uh
what you call a Garvey I eat I was with
some so called Garvey ice and what that
was was Marcus Garvey himself is a
progressive man he was more about a
building of stores and businesses for
the African people living in America but
the people I was with or more on like
trying to use racism to fight racism and
that doesn't work and it put a lot of
hate in my heart actually and it was
actually then after that I realized
that's not the truth and I kept touring
searched and kept on searching now I
finally came to Islam we saved my life a
brother from the corner store by the way
brother harmony he um he gave me a Quran
and then when he gave me the Quran start
reading it and then I seen that this
right here is the word about a lot of
this is the truth and then from there um
I came in a nut butter like couple
months later I ended up taking my
Shahada and I really felt a light enter
me I felt like a new man right then and
there and I couldn't stop
the whole day and then from there I just
been um just keep on learning keep on
learning I mean because you have to
learn from the cradle to the grave is
that you can never stop and um I'm just
so happy mashallah it's just a blessing
to be here because I know I like he
could have just kept my eyes closed he
could get my eyes closed now I've never
seen Islam so I'm very happy and I know
that took a while for me and find the
truth but I'm happy I found it martial
arts were talk a lot tell us now for
those people let's back it up a little
bit because I opened the show and I said
you almost were like worshipping this
man so people don't understand when we
say worship you know what that means
like because we try to reclaim our heart
from worshiping the material things from
worshiping the creation and only
worshiping the create tour right so now
you got Bob Marley and people he was
like a an icon right and and a big-time
celebrity and I mentioned your hair yeah
he had like this dizzy and natty dread
so what made you want to do that what
made you turn to like just idolizing him
how did that start
well it started off with me um you know
listen to the reggae and I was just try
and find I was just try and get more
into the culture you know I'm saying I
was just trying to learn more about
Africa and they're not hear of the
reggae music and I'm not disputing it by
any means but what happened was it end
up leading me first to worship in Haile
Selassie I who was who was the Emperor
of Ethiopia but in reality that is shirk
and I didn't even realize this cuz I
didn't know a shirk men at the time and
it was through Bob Marley's music which
led me to literally worshiping Haile
Selassie I and I'm he himself even Haile
Selassie I that's the Emperor of
Ethiopia and the oreos haile selassie
high heels Rastafari Makonnen Ross means
head and a Tabari
meant to be reverenced so that's how the
whole thing came along and so the
Jamaicans end up start to worship him
and they start growing out their dress
even though he himself didn't have the
locks
I guess they start growing the locks and
it just it just was a culture thing
where Austin I just came on to it and I
just started really trying to find out
more about Rasta so then I start
my natural hair and it was through the
music and I end up having like Bob
Marley posters everywhere I end up on I
was just really into it and to a point
where it took a while but finally my
shot a lot I saw the truth and by doing
that it just changed my life because my
whole thought process has changed now
and now I don't know there's only one
guy that's not a lot and it's not even
about where she's been no man because
Allah doesn't coming up for my man I
lies the most merciful he's a he's the
greatest he's most magnificent he can't
he won't come in the form of us so I'm
I'm just happy I think Islam is the
truth yeah mashallah we're gonna take a
break and for many of the not yet
Muslims on there they don't know see
when we say Allah I mean if you just you
know open your mind you see that Jesus
peace be upon him he spoke Aramaic and
he would say you know he was at Aloha a
la ilaha and Jews and Christians who are
Eric's Arabic speaking they used the
word Allah so we're not worshipping no
moon God or nothing we worshiping the
Creator amazing we're gonna continue on
with your story I'm gonna take a break
we're back with David here on the Deen
show
but you figure out that you know man has
to have a purpose if you were to take
away mosquitoes from the planet within a
few months everything dies if you just
took away what the mosquito when the
scale is in fact right that's a fact
mosquitoes mosquitoes but if you take
away mankind nothing happens so this
whole ecosystem this whole wheel in the
soul cycle does it need you so why are
you here
show us the way to other squids this is
30
this is the do you love his
subhanallah open hamdulillah I'm gonna
ilaha il'allah w'allahu akbar
I love egg-bound subhanAllah open
hamdulillah I'm glad he let her in na na
na egg bound i love egg bomb had allah
open hamdulillah I'm gonna ilaha
il'allah w'allahu akbar allah akbar
subhan allah wa l-hamdu lillah wa la
ilaha il'allah w'allahu akbar
I love egg-bound Allah and hamdulillah
la ilaha illallah w'allahu akbar i love
egg bomb subhanAllah open hamdulillah
I'm gonna ilaha il'allah w'allahu akbar
love egg bomb
back here on the d show with our brother
david continuing on with your wonderful
story so we know that when one accepts
the way of life that Jesus was upon
Abraham Moses and all the other
messengers that the Creator sent to
guide humanity because he loves humanity
and God didn't send messenger message
conflicting messages all of the
messengers came with the same message
worship the Creator not his creation and
do good be good be upon what God sent
and there's certain rituals that we do
the prayer the fasting and all of that
produces good to be good to your
neighbor to be good to your family you
know to feed the poor you know to do all
of these things to help you develop to
be the best human being possible now
that you can look back when you were
following Bob Marley ins how do you get
Rastafari Rastafari there are certain
rituals now that you look back oh yeah
talk to us about some of these rituals
and what did they produce I mean a pot
is a big big thing about it right music
and all these things talk to us about it
well first of all
we don't have to get into the details I
was gonna let you know that it is a
ritual basically because it comes with
the herb smoking and it comes with them
for the people that we got some some
uncle's here some elders and they don't
know what was that smoked marijuana it's
a lot of words weed I means a lot ways
you could put it but um yeah yeah
basically and so I mean I was I guess
just so high out of mind I didn't know
what reality was I mean it had me
basically bow down to a man basically
and you know in it and it my shot a lot
as soon as I came into Islam as soon
after the Shahada
it took the taste out of my mouth and I
just completely changed because it was
two things I never plan on changing in
my life one was I cleaner and growing my
dress till they till I died and two was
I never end up never plainer in stop
smoking herb I mean it was something
that my family all distraught like they
was really upset about this you know I
mean like and when I came to Islam I
didn't even want to do these things you
know I'm saying it's like now that I
didn't need to I just didn't want to and
so just grown or in my life it was just
a process it was just a process coming
in I got stay from Christianity then to
Rastafari and then from there I was like
I said with the Garvey ice and then
that's when I like was more of getting
away from Rasta and more into just
trying to be like more of um just a
black nationalist and but with this
right here the people I were with I was
with they were actually in reality
counter-revolutionary
con artists black capitalists darkman
'test and that's the full title because
it was more like a con game and I mean
at one point in time they even told me
what they was giving me wasn't even
legit but I'm so into wherever I put my
life into that I was ready to if it
wasn't for his time I'll probably be
gone in two or three years just because
I was just so rated just like I hate the
world almost and me myself personally I
look at myself as a revolutionary in a
sense that means changed and that means
to do about within a process like peace
and I know that there's injustice I know
there's fascism and I'm the type of guy
who wants to just rid away all evils and
bring about Islam and I know that Islam
is the answer and
people needed to know the truth so
that's how come I wanna put myself in a
position to help the people and do
whatever I can and just be a vessel and
just spread this light because I know
that it changed my life and I know if it
can change my life it can change
everybody's life absolutely absolutely
and most people don't know that Muslims
a Muslim is simply an Arabic word which
means one who has submitted to God an
Islam for the night yet Muslims who are
watching us is something that Jesus was
upon when you learned that wasn't that
fast negative
what do you mean Jesus was upon Islam
because every messenger submitted to the
will of God that's what Islam means
submission to the will of God right
natural human being not to a man a
monkey a stick or a stone or to Bob
Marley but to the Creator and didn't now
you made an interesting term because
okay you following Bob Marley and then
he actually becomes he went towards
Christianity Christian matter of fact um
that's yes there's another thing on the
helmet is life later or in the final
stages of his life he actually went to
the Ethiopian Orthodox Tewahedo Church
and that's more of the Orthodox to
Christianity and actually that's where I
ended up going to it and Buffalo because
I was like I said whenever I put my life
into our one Bowl 100% and so I went
into Ethiopian Orthodox Church which is
similar in some ways but the part that
they're wrong with is still dessert
because I mean they have the women with
their hair wrapped up they still
prostrate but yeah they still giving
them things and praises to Esau and we
know that it's all you give your things
appraisers the one guy which is a lot
and there's no partners with no partners
and so then from there I um I was
learning something and I'm hearing
that's like the Ethiopian language now
and I have books on it I got actually
I'm hearing dictionary because I really
wanted to know the language and and
shout aloud
one day I'll still be able to go to
Africa but it's gonna be for a different
agenda now I want to just go around the
world to show people Islam I want to
first go to Mecca and complete my five
pillars of faith and but I plan on
really just spread this truth to the
whole four corners of the world
inshaallah and hopefully a lot makes it
easy for me because my heart is for the
people and it's just to change this
reality to transform this paradigm
masha'Allah you see the zeal in you and
hopefully people have got a little bit
stagnant with there you know what their
Deen and taking it for granted they can
see there
gift when somebody investigates and they
do their homework and they conclude that
you know what this car on the verbatim
word of God is not from a human being
but is from the Creator that have is an
earth Islam is not a man-made religion
organized by man or men but it's indeed
a system a way of life that's from the
Creator I'm gonna appreciate it more
it's a gift like you do you can see you
just excited about it so what was it
about this way of life Islam submission
to the will of God that convinced you
finally that it took you over you're
like you know what this has got to be
from the crater what was it but it was
was it was just the fact that I seen
that it was just a brotherly love you
know I mean it wasn't no backstabbin I
mean it came to a point in time where
like say some brother gave me something
but all right brother I'll be back no no
I want your money I want the best for my
life and it was just time and time again
just the generosity just a true
Brotherhood the fact that the Masjid is
open every single day it's not open for
just one day out of week for three hours
it's open non-stop and from Pfizer to
each other you could go in and learn and
I just love and that's how I am because
like I'm a true seeker and I want to
stay inside where I could get this
knowledge this obligatory knowledge of
Islam so I could just stay strong in his
Deen because there's nothing like Islam
and nothing else would have changed my
life but Islam and um I'm just so happy
that like I said a lot of open my eyes
to it because I could have just been
left deaf dumb and blind and I could
just be a wander in the wilderness but
he showed me the way he he showed me the
spiritual path the road to righteousness
and it's my job to just stay or knit and
so that on one day and I could make it
to Jenna because with me I don't want to
just be in Jenna I want to be in the
presence of Allah I want to be one with
the Creator I want to be in the highest
level of Jenna because just being an
agenda to me wouldn't be good enough I
want to be in the highest level I want
to do ever I can now in the dunya so
that I could make it to the farthest
level I can in Jenna so that's how I am
and that's what all the messengers of
God brought and taught they called
people to be attached to the creator and
not his creation and be striving for its
paradise to be the best in this world
that you can be to be excellent doctors
lawyers engineers whatever but don't
sell yourself out you so your honor your
soul your dignity look for it for this
life because pretty soon is going to be
over you're going to have
you can't take it with you you go right
so work hard for the hereafter be the
best in this life and that's what this
way of life is calling us to to really
reflect and you're doing that now
so tell us when you hear like when you
turn on Fox News CNN and you hear some
of these stereotypes somebody's you know
things that are attributed to Islamic
say hey look have you had some
resistance people are all now you're a
terrorist
have you ever hear some of these this
baloney phony what do you got to say
about that well me personally I was
always someone who was vocal about these
things I always spoke on about these
things even before I came into Islam
auto-racing injustice because I know
that the TV is just an illusion it's
just a beast and it's telling live
vision because they telling lies to your
vision and I never was with that I
already knew that Islam was a religion
of peace and how can someone be a
terrorist when they're defend their
their their country their people the
terrorists other wants was bombing
people day in and day out and then
drones over killing innocent women and
children
those are terrorists but now Muslims say
that now they're looked at as the
terrorists because people are like in
the matrix and they don't know the truth
they haven't woken up and for me I
already knew even before coming into
this Deen that Islam was never like that
but now being a Muslim I really see it's
not like that we're generous kind loving
people and for me to be even a
revolutionary would be for them to try
point a finger say I'm some terrorist
guy why because I want change because
that's what revolution is is a change
and so you know I mean they always try
and give us a bad look but if you know
of the history of a lot of people they
were usually always the one that's being
persecuted so people should look at that
and say well you know what if Islam is
getting such a bad rap maybe this is the
truth because everything is reversed in
this reality the deal that they make
good they they haven't be bad things
that is bad they make it look good and
that's just how it is so they should
people should really look at more into
Islam and see what it's about and like
you said self develop and that's what
it's about do you see yourself having
better character the kind of to your
parents you know you're just a better
human being
overall you're kinder you're more
merciful and you have this peace yes I
don't look at myself as a kinder person
you know because I'm before Islam I was
on just to his strong you know me as
either like my way or the highway stop
for a lot I gave my parents a hard time
some
you know I mean and even sometimes
disrespectful when it hurt me at the
time but I didn't know how to really
change it then when I came into Islam it
allowed me to really just apologize to
the mid allowed me to really just open
up more to them and you know listen more
you know I mean and not just think I
know everything because as soon as you
realize that you don't know anything
that's when you're opened up to learn
everything because we have an open mind
you can absorb everything around you
move your closed mind and tunnel vision
you're gonna have a lot of things pass
you through so with me I open up my
heart and my mind and I just Islam
really just changed my character it
allowed me to just change the things
that was gonna lead me down and allow me
to just stay doing things that's gonna
bring me up we're gonna take a break
David and we right back with more of
David story here on the Dean show so as
the last and final messenger sent to
mankind the Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him he told us to really reflect
often about death reflect upon the
destroyer of pleasures many of us are
delighting in our lusts and our passions
were chasing this world we're chasing
that dollar we're chasing all the
material things we're working on our
physical physique and working on our
minds but the soul we're neglecting it
so before a situation comes where you
might end up in a hospital you might end
up with no legs you might end up with no
eyes you might end up in a situation
that you won't be able to even make a
prostration to your crater you won't
even be able to do the things that
you're doing now some of the hard hearts
that just have gone away that they've
made money they're gone
they've made a woman their God they've
made a man their God that's all they
think about is the next party or the
next good time but as you see if
tomorrow you get hit by a truck or a car
or you fall from a fall tall building or
you get cancer or you get a disease that
you're not
you're terminally ill and now you you
lose all these wonderful benefits take
advantage of your health now and use it
in the proper way if you're Muslim you
know that as Muslims we need to be
praying we need to be establishing that
direct connection with our minimum five
times a day we need to stay away from
the things that are displeasing to God
Almighty we need to pray to Him alone
and not his creation we need to follow
the Sunnah the way of the last and final
messenger sent to mankind and stay away
from gambling and alcohol and drugs
promiscuity
there's no dating in Islam and many of
the youth are caught up on the Facebook
and using them in an unproductive way so
if you see if you're a young boy or
young girl and you have parents and
you're disrespecting your parents this
can be you tomorrow it can be you
tomorrow that now your health that now
you might be playing soccer baseball
football and now you get hit and you end
up paralyzed or you end up getting
struck down and you're in the hospital
and it's almost flatline now is the time
that Angel of Death can come at any time
Malakal molt he's there waiting so are
you prepared for that moment that moment
when your soul will be extracted from
your body are you ready to meet your
Creator when you're six feet under five
feet under in the ground and the dirt is
thrown over your body then it's too late
now is the time
back here on the D show with David who
went from worshiping a man we talked
about Bob Marley
big icon your most prostrating to him
huh doing [ __ ] polytheism right paganism
to doing something that's you know in
every human beings nature you know what
never is called the fifth and you didn't
become an Arab you're an American
I'm an American and we're Muslim right
where once who have submitted to the
will of God Jesus was a Muslim Moses was
a Muslim Abraham and all the messengers
of God people say Wyatt yeah they
submitted to the will of God that's what
a Muslim is is that now now that you're
one who's to reclaim your heart from
loving you know the material things and
the creation like you should love the
creator to loving the creator and
wanting to do all the good things that
he told you to do but you see now
sometimes as those who are born in a
Muslim family you might have got to
experience that so what advice do you
have for Muslims who aren't appreciating
their Islam I'm having you say that the
way I looked at it is coming into Islam
before Islam I look at myself as like a
poor beggar almost looking for crumbs
and for crumbs and as soon as I came
into the Masjid that's the palace I'm
rich now the only problem is I realize
that sometimes I'm some people I was
born into Islam it's kinda like being
born like a prince you know I mean a
princess where you already used to
royalty so so you kind of take it for
granted you don't really know what you
have but this Deen this is the drill
deal this is the truth and and I kind of
think I live for them put me outside
into in the darkness first to now be
able to see the light because now I just
appreciate it so much more because I
know I know the darkness and believe me
that's not the way to go that's gonna
send you right to Jahannam but when I
say that this is the truth it makes me
have a even stronger still and want to
just learn more and so that's why I want
11 the Muslims that's born into Islam
know that listen don't go astray what
you have right here is the truth and
there's nothing else but Islam this is
the way the truth and the life and
that's why I just want to just reaffirm
myself and let people see that listen if
this could changed me then
you already in it you there ain't
nowhere else to go you know I mean
because I'm people should be rushing to
Islam rather than try and see okay what
this do you have for me because it's
doing it got death that's what the dunya
have for you has a straight death and
corruption but Islam that could give you
eternal bliss in the hereafter and sha
Allah as long as you stay on your Deen
then Allah will make it easy for you
tell us share before we cut out we have
a few more minutes about your father who
might watch this oh yeah you know tell
us I heard that you're also sharing you
know your experiences with him and how's
that coming along actually come along
very beautiful you know I'm he's being
real receptive he's real receptive to
Islam you know I get more Quran Iginla's
a DVD or in Islam matter of fact even
yesterday come to speak of it he will
show me some some service in the Quran
he was like hey hey OH dong goo they dug
you should check this out because I was
talking about some issues I'm having in
this ad there and he showed me a surah
surah forewarn and to help
we gotta fight me and it was just
beautiful you know I'm saying cuz I see
my father actually reading the Quran of
me and I'm like a lot of wet bar this is
beautiful because I'm hopefully in
shower one day he could actually confirm
this be a big confirmed Muslim say
Shahada and hopefully we get each other
both in gender one day but I'm just
happy that he's very receptive to this
and hopefully I could just get my whole
family into I got my one my one cause I
ain't getting nothing this is all a lot
my shout loud my one cousin took his
Shahada and now he's a Muslim and
hopefully could just be a domino effect
and the whole family could see Islam is
the truth I know I believe by example
out to be a living example so now I can
just turn back and do what I used to do
because then I'll be a better example
and the thing I don't like the thing I
despise worse is the one
representing this one because then
they're the ones who people say what was
the difference if this person's doing
that and that person is me that's why we
have to really make sure we stay on our
team so we don't have other people
astray who may be searching for Islam
yeah the beautiful thing is that in
Islam you know if you look at cities
Lamas love all mankind right so how do
you feel now for you have you know our
brothers in humanity and people just
don't know but you were there yesterday
some are here today so do you get
excited now to share because we care and
it's an obligation on every Muslim to
share the purpose of life so have you
had some of your friends also we talked
about your father that you you know had
an opportunity now to to share you know
Islam submission to the will of God with
them and how's that been it's been all
right like with me on my money is down
without Limon and that was a key part of
my life because I feel like we have to
give down this is an obligation as a
Muslim to share this is Dina get out
those people my friends in particular
they um they're seeing it but um they're
they're more trying to stay in the dunya
I mean they really just party and do
whatever it is that that police have for
them but um I mean inshallah hopefully
they can see more you know I mean I can
see that this is the real dough and you
know blue in your bio can go so far and
but I'm en shaa allah may Allah make it
easy for them and may I just keep lead
by example so that you see how this deen
is for real I want to thank you and may
the Creator that happens at her continue
to bless you and keep you firm and you
know help you and help your father
hopefully he'll see this and he'll get
you know one step forward even more so
and accept this beautiful way of life
and
and you're the rest of your family and
we make due out for them thank you so
much again I'm just like all okay your
brother buy me some run I'm very
appreciative I'm happy that you even
gave me opportunity that's it run
Thank You Milla blessing sonic takbir
and another wonderful story another
human being who made that conscious
decision I'm not gonna worship the
creation but I'm gonna worship the
Creator doesn't that make sense we
talked about all of these things men
that people are worshipping sticks and
stones and bones and man and women but
when one realizes uses the common sense
the intellect that the Creator has given
us that I don't want to worship the
creation I want to worship the creator
and this life is short so I better get
with it what's the purpose of life why
have I been created to amass a lot of
wealth and money go to parties and
nightclubs and just listen to music all
day and dancing and dining and what the
end death comes and I did live my
purpose and then what it's all over no
it's a paradise and there's a Hellfire
what did I work for that I work for the
parallel paradise then I obey my Creator
did I do all the wonderful things that
he's told me to do because Islam is the
best self-defense
keeps me away from alcoholism drugs and
gambling and fornication and an adultery
teaches me to be the best human being to
be upright to be honest to be just
doesn't that make sense look into Islam
give us a call 1 800 662 you and even
your criticisms are work welcome come on
give us those two let's start a healthy
dialogue and we hope to see you next
time
tune in every week to the Deen show
until then peace be unto you
so I just want to remind everybody at
hamdulillah help us to get this message
out like I said take the bumper stickers
you can join us also on Facebook like us
there the more people that we have
supporting the more we can use the
social media in a positive way to help
get the message out so you can find us
on Twitter on Facebook go tonight most
of the people are using those and go to
our Facebook page
join it so you can follow our programs
and let's do our best to live this way
of life that's pleasing to the Creator
before we meet the Creator and let's
connect with him through the Quran
through the Quran let's learn to
implement it in our lives let's not let
it be a book that we just bring down off
the shelf when someone dies and then we
open it up we Ramadan comes and we get
the dust off it so as the prophet
salallahu alayhi wasalam said al-quran
hooda to look at our lake the quran will
either be an evidence for you were
against you and one of the great Sahaba
even Masood ready Aloha
he said commenting on this hadith he
said that the Quran will come on the day
of judgement and for the person who read
it implemented it live by it it will
intercede for that person and got him
into Jenna but for the one now that
turned his back on it I'm a law protect
us from that that we don't turn our back
away we study hard to become the best in
school and pass our exams but if we
neglect the verbatim word of the Creator
the Quran then it will be an
intersession on the day of judgment that
will lead us into the hellfire be a
witness against us so this small piece
of advice for myself first and foremost
is that we connect with our Creator
through this book the Quran
and the Sunnah of the final messenger
sent to mankind the Prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alayhe wassallam
do we love him so we have to implement
his Sunnah his way so let's do that
let's leave today being better
worshipers of the Creator than we were
yesterday and keep developing ourselves
to be the best human beings that we can
and we can only wake it we the only way
we can do that is by following the
blueprint otherwise we're following our
fancies our whims and desires so let's
not do that and hope we can all gather
together in Jannah and Allah the most
merciful can forgive us for all of our
shortcomings meet first and foremost so
thank you very much for attending I love
being and your company I'll hum did
Allah make go out for us and we hope to
be with you again sometime to future
it's a way of life or to us bad the
messenger best of me show us the way to
others Chris this is the dhih dhih
nervous man
this is the dhih dhih nervous
you